pues por el momento lo que se sabe es
que el ataque tuvo lugar a unos 10 km de
la ciudad de goma esto es en la zona
este del país el embajador se encontraba
a bordo de un vehículo que hacía parte
de un convoy de dos automóviles del
programa mundial de alimentos al parecer
estos automóviles no iban escoltados por
militares y cayeron en una emboscada
hombres armados asesinaron primero al
chofer y después al guardaespaldas y
finalmente hirieron gravemente al
embajador quien murió posteriormente en
un hospital cercano el ataque por el
momento no ha sido reivindicado pero se
sabe que en esta zona operan varios
grupos armados de la república
democrática del congo y natalia que
reacciones en italia del interior del
país se podrían destacar al momento
pues la muerte de este embajador ha
generado una ola de conmoción profunda
aquí en italia en las últimas horas las
reacciones se han multiplicado en el
mundo político y diplomático italia está
de luto estas fueron las palabras del
presidente italiano sergio matar el a
quien denunció un ataque cobarde por su
parte el jefe del gobierno italiano
mario draghi manifestó su solidaridad a
las familias del embajador y de sus
acompañantes el canciller italiano luigi
de mayo supo la noticia
estando en bélgica pues se devolvió
inmediatamente en urgencia a roma' en un
comunicado deploró la desaparición de
dos servidores del estado italiano
ejemplares la fiscalía de roma ha
abierto una investigación una equipo de
detectives e italianos llegará aquí
hinchas a la mañana que hinchas a que es
la capital de la república democrática
halcón
natalia muchísimas gracias por este
completísimo reporte desde la capital
italiana